welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we break
down all the latest movies games TV
shows and comics this episode were going
over the new Netflix horror film wounds
starring army hammer and Suzy beets
throughout the video we'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the film including the major plot
points curse and ending there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch wounds yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of wounds
we follow will a bartender that works at
a rundown and cockroach infested bar
known as Rosie's in New Orleans will
spends most of his time on the job
hanging out with Alicia and the
boyfriend Jeffrey as well as a man named
Eric who gets pretty aggressive when
drunk one night a fight breaks out in
which Eric gets stabbed in the cheek
with a broken bottle and all hell breaks
loose in the bar a group of college
students who are also at the location
filmed the incident on their phones and
after the fight spills over into where
they're sitting they quickly leave when
everything quietens down at will
discovers one of their phones takes it
home and so begins the curse of wounds
after unlocking it he begins to receive
strange messages from a boy named
Garrett who says he's being followed by
something and though will casts the
phone aside he awakens the next morning
to find more messages including one that
shows a photo of teeth in a puddle of
blood will drops his girlfriend Kerry
off at college and he begins to suspect
that she's cheating on him from the
interactions that we see between the two
it's clear that they aren't really
compatible with each other
Kerry seems to mock well about his job
as a bartender and we get the impression
that he is very much stuck in a toxic
relationship and meaningless career that
is leading him to be unhappy a lot of
the time we'll visits Eric to discover
that the wound on his face is starting
to become infected
but Eric refuses to have any treatment
after receiving another message from the
students telling him to in
expect the phone once more he notices
some photos of a severed head and a
video of one being surrounded by
cockroaches that seemingly has a hand
popping out of one of the wounds in it
will shows this to his girlfriend and in
the back of the photo they know it's a
book named the translation of wounds
after calling Garrett and hearing
nothing but screeching strange things
begin to happen including shadows that
appear and disappear in their apartment
and horrifying hallucinations that haunt
will will gets rid of the phone but that
doesn't stop the curse which now has
itself fixated on the character it's a
pretty interesting premise and though I
feel like wounds fail slightly in its
execution of delivering adequate answers
there's still some things that are part
of the film that definitely have the
creep factor now before we get into the
rest of the plot I'm just going to
discuss what the curse is how it works
and why certain things happen in the
movie we learn that the students have
been dabbling in the occult and that
they brought forth something terrible
from practicing things laid out in the
translation of wounds the book which the
movie is based on named the visible
filth by Nathan ballin Grodd describes
the translation of wounds as an ancient
belief system that requires its
followers to reject the material world
in order to have a deeper connection
with the spirit realm in this spirit
realm exists a dark God that calls forth
creatures known as ions that can
interact with humans and act as a bridge
between the two dimensions Garrett and
Co was studying this and through the
books and researching things online
they tried some of the rituals out
summoning creatures for three wounds
which act as portals this is why they
were carrying out the rituals on
decapitated heads as they need something
that was once living or is alive in
order for it to work the ceremonies can
only exist through pain and flesh and
this is why they become fixated on will
Eric and so on we'll get into what
happens later on in the film but the
movie becomes very much about will
accepting and embracing this ideology
after his life begins to fall apart or
rather improves depending on how you
look at it well is informed by one of
the kids that he has been chosen and
they slowly begin to stalk him in
addition to this we'll hallucinates
cockroaches almost everywhere and they
slowly begin to infest his life after
making a move on Alicia
he wants them to be together this is
rejected because Alicia says that she
still loves Jeffrey and will ends up
going back to his car where he receives
a strange message from Kerry that
further pushes his paranoia will also
hallucinates Kara in his home who
informs him that he is the perfect
vessel Kerry and well get more and more
distant and his hallucinations increase
he also gets into a fight with Jeffrey
over the Alesha incident and after
receiving more strange messages from
Kerry he goes home to discover her
transfixed on something on the computer
she's completely unresponsive and only
after almost drowning her does he manage
to get her out of this state the next
day the two break up and will calls
Alicia repeatedly who after ignoring him
multiple times eventually answers and
tells him to stop will breaks down and
goes on a bender and quits his job after
getting into an argument with Rosie and
after receiving a message he goes to
Eric's and tells him that he needs a
place to stay
eric says that the college kids broke in
and made him lure will there and that
they have a present for him Eric leads
will to his room way finds the phone and
they say that the gift is wrapped in
flesh will realizes that the kids broke
in performed the ritual and Eric's wound
and he calls Garrett to initiate a
screeching sound which completes the
ritual and allows the creature to crawl
forth will embracing the fact that his
life is pretty meaningless submits of
the higher power and allows himself to
become a vessel and hold on a second
what the hell just happened okay so I'm
gonna try and explain this as best I can
so throughout the film we just watched
we'll beat from pillar to post both
mentally physically and spiritually
by the end of the film the guy has lost
it all and is in a really really bad
state well is an alcoholic doesn't
really have any friends outside of
customers and is probably being cheated
on by his girlfriend who doesn't really
have a very high opinion of him when the
students call him the perfect vessel
they mean because the guy is pre-built
like who remembers when army hammer was
cast as a Batman in the failed George
Miller Justice League movie I do anyway
it's that reason and because he's also
someone who will likely submit to the
creature because things aren't exactly
going his way in the case of Garrett he
was probably not willing to submit and
was killed for it unless the students
decided
pass the curse over to will who was far
more likely to give in by the end carry
remarks to will at one point that he has
become Hollow simply going through the
motions of his job and this builds the
picture in his mind that he is the
perfect candidate to be taken over now
throughout the movie will is constantly
haunted by cockroaches and on a
metaphorical level that these represent
the stale surroundings that he's become
involved in as well as the fact that the
Aeon is slowly song to take over him in
the end due to the collapse of his
relationship the rejection by Alesha the
loss of his home and job he just ends up
giving in because if he is part of
something better then that will surely
be an improvement over the circumstances
that he's currently in now though the
film might and negatively in some
people's eyes it actually has a more
positive meaning behind it once you
scratch the surface wounds is about
improving your life and it carries the
message of getting rid of things that
are holding you back whether this is a
toxic relationship that makes you
paranoid and jealous or a dead-end job
that isn't really going anywhere
wound says that if you lose these things
there may be something better at the end
of the rainbow now whilst I admit it's
not really presented in this way due to
the amount of cockroaches and things
popping out people's faces wounds
overall leaves well with something that
will give his life meaning and hopefully
take him out of the neverending monotony
of his life though the film cuts just as
things get interesting we do know that
the character has become something new
no longer held back by the trappings of
mediocrity and he will have something to
live for just don't come near me yeah
without thing popping out your face
overall it's not the completely
downtrodden ending that you might think
and there's actually some nice subtext
to it but what did I think about wounds
overall well whilst the premise and
message behind the movie are interesting
I feel that wounds fall slightly flat in
its execution and no will leads a very
monotonous life that doesn't mean that
the viewer should be subjected to it
either wounds has a really interesting
backstory and subtext but none of this
really makes its way to the screen and
because of the lack of many things I
mentioned not being present in the film
it makes watching it slightly boring now
the book is definitely worth picking up
if this video has piqued your interest
by
if you don't have knowledge of it then I
can imagine a lot of this movie seeming
pointless and underdeveloped wounds is
okay but it doesn't do anything
spectacular and when compared to
Netflix's other film release last
weekend eli pales in comparison
overall I doubt I'll ever go back to
wounds and I'll probably have forgotten
what happens in it by the end of this
sentence so it gets a 4 out of 10
well wait what were we talking about
again
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on wounds and what you took
from the film and where they see well as
having a downward or upward spiral
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the aforementioned horror movie Eli
which would be linked at the end I go
over the entire film and give my
interpretation on it so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more you want to come chat to me after
the video then make sure you follow me
on twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which would be
linked in the description below those
are the best ways to keep up to date
with the channel and all the latest
videos so hopefully I see you over on
one of them very soon we're also giving
away a free copy of the Marvel phase 3
part 1 box on blu-ray which contains
Civil War Doctor Strange homecoming
Ragnarok and more and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning it so
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on wounds in the comments
section below the winners gonna be
chosen on the 15th of November and the
set will be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]